Purposes hook up culture is a cancer to society.
So many young people are brainwashed via social media,
TV, movies to mindlessly smash more bait using each other's bodies.
And in order to do this,
one must dissociate
or disconnect from their physical and emotional body.
Women especially are biologically inferior,
physiologically wired to attach to their sexual partner.
Men are too, in a way,
but that's a discussion for another day.
Sacred energy exchange can either deplete you or expand you.
Amplify your darkness or or amplify your love.
Light and inspiration
within the container of a monogamous relationship with a safe partner
is how we truly experience the depths of real intimacy
and real human connection.